la séance est reprise et l'ordre du jour
appelle la question orale numéro 308 de
monsieur philippe dallier à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur merci monsieur
le président à ma question s'adresse à
monsieur manuel valls au ministre de
l'intérieur
en 2011 la loi dite loppsi 2 a créé le
conseil national des activités privées
de sécurité le cnaps établissement
public administratif placé sous la
tutelle de votre ministère monsieur le
ministre
depuis le 1er janvier 2012 cet organisme
est notamment chargé au nom de l'êta de
la régulation de l'accès aux activités
privées de sécurité
à ce titre il contrôle les
professionnels qu'ils soient les
personnes morales ou physiques et
délivre les agréments nécessaires à
l'exercice de ces professions pour
bénéficier d'une autorisation d'exercer
ou de se former à ces métiers
le demandeur doit évidemment ne pas
avoir commis d'actes répréhensibles est
incompatible avec la profession cette
condition impérative et bien sûr
vérifier par le cnaps avant toute
délivrance de titres dans le cadre de ce
contrôle le cnaps est amené à instruire
deux types de dossiers sur les personnes
souhaitant accéder à une formation avant
de demander la délivrance d'une carte
professionnelle d'agent privées de
sécurité ou ceux des personnes en voie
de recrutement par une entreprise de
sécurité privée leur garantissant
ensuite une formation en vue de
satisfaire à la condition d'aptitude
professionnelle la procédure d'examen
des dossiers aboutis si la décision de
la délégation territoriale du cnaps
compétentes et positives soit à la
délivrance d'un numéro d'autorisation
préalable dans le premier cas où à la
provisoire dans le second cas ces
numéros sont obligatoires et doivent
donc avoir été transmis au préalable par
le cnaps pour que le candidat puisse
valider soit le contrat de travail ou
son inscription auprès d'un organisme de
formation voilà mais je ne lis mes chers
collègues pour la théorie
mais dans la pratique il semble que des
délais anormalement longs pour
l'instruction des dossiers et la
délivrance des numéros d'autorisation
voix voire parfois même la non réponse
de l'administration pénalise fréquemment
temps les candidats à ces métiers que
les entreprises pourtant prête à les
recruter
je souhaiterais donc monsieur le
ministre que vous puissiez me préciser
plusieurs points
tout d'abord la durée moyenne
actuellement constatés pour l'un
truction des dossiers d'autorisation
quels sont les objectifs assignés au
cnaps
quels sont les indicateurs de
performance il en existe et les
instructions de votre ministère quels
sont les moyens attribués aux
délégations territoriales pour
l'exercice de leur mission ces moyens
sont ils suffisants et enfin quelles
sont les mesures que vous pourriez
prendre monsieur le ministre pour
améliorer l'amélioration de la procédure
d'instruction est notamment raccourcir
les délais merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à monsieur manuel valls
ministre de l'intérieur merci monsieur
le président tout les excuses pour le
léger retard monsieur le sénateur
philippe dallier vous m'interrogez donc
sur les délais d'instruction des
dossiers par le conseil national des
activités privées de sécurité
vous le savez vous l'avez rappelé le
conseil national des activités privées
de sécurité assume une triple mission de
police administrative disciplinaire et
conseil et d'assistance à la profession
les organes du cnaps collège commission
nationale d'agrément et de contrôle
commissions régionales interrégionales
ou locales ou local d'agrément et de
contrôle du ciac ont été installés en
janvier-février 2012
le déploiement 17 délégations
territoriales du cnaps s'est effectuée
de manière progressive tout au long de
l'année 2012
le transfert de ses compétences des
préfectures à l'établissement public
s'est effectuée en deux étapes
à compter de leur installation effective
en février 2012
les six axes sont prononcés dans un
premier temps sur des dossiers qui
continuent à être instruit par les
préfectures
dans un second temps au fur et à mesure
que s'ouvraient les délégations
territoriales
l'instruction des dossiers a été assurée
par les personnels du cnaps
si ces transitions successives ont
généré au premier semestre quelques
difficultés vous l'avez rappelé ces
retards ponctuelles dans la délivrance
des titres se sont résorbés dans les
semaines qui ont suivi l'ouverture des
délégations territoriales peut y avoir
ici ou là encore évidemment quelques
difficultés le cnaps ainsi dès la
première année produit 80 3408 décision
conduisant à la délivrance de 75 mille
trois cent cinquante cinq cartes
professionnelles et autorisation
préalable
certaines délégations ont dû en effet
faire face à une augmentation des
demandes lors du dernier trimestre 2012
cette hausse s'explique pour partie par
le caractère dissuasif des 826 contrôles
effectués par le cnaps en 2012
s'agissant des délais la notification de
l'autorisation préalable ou provisoire
comme de celle de la carte
professionnelle s'effectue aujourd'hui
pour 80 % des dossiers dans un délai
moyen de 10 jours suivant l'envoi par la
délégation territoriale de l'accusé de
réception attestant de la complétude du
dossier dans les 20 % de cas restants la
durée de traitement des demandes et plus
longue
ck correspondent à des situations dans
lesquelles une enquête approfondie doit
être menée par les services de police et
de gendarmerie afin de satisfaire aux
conditions exigées par la loi je l' ai
moi-même rappelait d'ailleurs devant le
cnaps en effet les agents du cnaps en
charge de l'instruction des demandes
d'autorisation doivent lorsque les
antécédents judiciaires sont constatées
saisir les services de police et de
gendarmerie pour connaître les raisons
précises ayant justifié cette mention et
vérifier si elles sont ou non
compatibles avec la délivrance de
l'autorisation sollicitée faut également
obtenir la position de l'autorité
judiciaire
la collaboration vertueuse entre le
cnaps et les services concernés aubure
je crois à court terme de
l'harmonisation des modalités de
traitement des enquêtes de mode de
moralité et de réduction des délais par
ailleurs les expertises acquises par les
agents du cnac ajoutée aux effets des
démarches en cours pour optimiser le
concours d'instruction et les systèmes
d'information associés devrait je
l'espère c'est attendu ainsi produire
leurs effets dès 2013 et la combinaison
de ces facteurs contribuera à
l'amélioration du délai de traitement
des demandes d'autorisation et de cartes
professionnelles formulées par les
futurs agents de sécurité privés le
ministère de l'intérieur en tant que
tutelle de l'établissement public veille
attentivement à l'amélioration de la
qualité du service proposé par le cnaps
et à la réduction des délais de
traitement
la moralisation de
ce secteur sa professionnalisation but
que je crois nous partageons tous sont
évidemment au coeur des priorités et de
l'établissement public et de la
profession est évidemment du ministère
nous rentrons je crois dans une année
qui devrait permettre les améliorations
c'est ce que je voulais vous répondre
monsieur le sénateur merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur d'allier je me hisse
merci de ces éléments de réponse et de
l'espoir d' améliorations que vous nous
laissait envisager et métiers la
sécurité je sais pas s'il faut s'en
féliciter ou le regretter mais c'est
ainsi ce sont des grands pourvoyeurs
d'emplois et dans un département comme
le mien la seine-saint-denis où beaucoup
de jeunes en difficulté et sans
véritable qualification peuvent dans
cette voie là effectivement espérer
trouver un emploi alors je comprends
tout à fait qu'il faille vérifier la
manière la plus sérieuse possible
notamment lorsque ces emplois sont
proposés sur les plates formes
aéroportuaires effectivement il faut
prendre le temps nécessaire
ceci étant dit dans un passé tout à fait
récent j'ai été en contact à la fois
avec des organismes de formation et avec
des professionnels qui m'ont
effectivement fait part de leurs
difficultés pour des des cas personnels
qui a priori ne devait pas poser de
souci particulier
donc j'espère effectivement que les
améliorations que vous nous promettez
pour l'année 2013 seront au rendez vous
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie
merci monsieur d'allier caisse